let's take it to the meme territory we
got this story from the washington post
quote we are closer to civil war than
any of us would like to believe new
study says this is from
barbara f walter university of
california at
san diego serves on a cia advisory panel
called the political instability task
force that monitors countries around the
world and predicts which of them are
most at risk of deteriorating into
violence by law the task force can't
assess what's happening with the within
the united states but walter a longtime
friend who has spent her career studying
conflicts in syria lebanon northern
ireland sri lanka the philippines rwanda
angola nicaragua and elsewhere applied
the predictive techniques herself to
this country her bottom line is that we
are closer to civil war than any of us
would like to believe she lays out the
argument in detail in her new book now
i'll pause here
could she just be trying to sell a book
she's an expert on civil war she wants
people to read about her area of
expertise she sees conflict in this
country and then tells everybody and
then they eat it up or let me read this
they're going to say indeed the u.s has
already gone through what the cia
identifies as the first two phases of
insurgency the pre-insurgency and
incipient conflict phases and only time
will tell whether the final phase open
insurgency began with the sacking of the
capital by donald trump supporters on
january 6.
i would like to interject good friends
at the washington post let me just add a
sentence and only time will tell whether
the final phase open insurgency began
with the sacking of cities across the
country by black lives matter and antifa
following the george floyd incident
you see they totally they totally skip
over that and act like we didn't deal
with a hundred plus days of violent
ridings and dozens dead however
this is the point i want to get to
is this woman who is a cia advisor who
tells them when other countries are
going to break down in a civil war is
she just selling a book or is this legit
that's a very good question because you
could be absolutely right it could be
sensationalistic it could be hyperbolic
but there are signs that do prove some
merit in her conversation now the
comment that i would add to this if
there is one government secretive agency
that knows about civil war it's the one
that has been spreading civil wars all
around the world and that of course is
the cia which they have been doing all
over latin america all over the you know
asian countries all over the middle east
so so i mean obviously she comes from a
perspective where she also has
information where she's privy to that we
don't know anything about so when you
look at the information
that she's able to declassify the
databases she's able to go into she
might be seeing something that that that
we're not allowed to know that could be
still classified that does show this
kind of bigger partisanship this kind of
bigger conflict brewing because we've
been talking about it for a very long
time and and the conditions that create
this kind of partisanship uh big tech
social media and the corporate media
they work in tandem to divide people
politically those two ingredients that
that fuel for this fire isn't stopping
it's only getting more powerful it's
only becoming more readily available and
it's only becoming something that we
can't avoid even more so the conditions
that create these civil war-like aspects
they're not going away they're only
becoming stronger i'll throw it to the
january 6th story we were just talking
about yep when you've got an overtly
political politicized government you
know body yeah issuing subpoenas on a
and going after with legal power and
criminal charges against former members
members of the for of the previous
administration i'm like dude it's wild
you know man i've been talking about
this for a long time and i i'm not
saying i know for sure exactly what will
happen but at a certain
point i really want to swear and i'm
going to do it at a certain
point man at a certain
point okay i said it twice all right
just so you know i'm serious right after
it starts with me being like hey look
people are beating each other in the
streets and this ideology is is you know
this divide is getting worse when you've
got
what happened with george floyd protests
riots
several dozen dead when you get january
6th when you have
a panel of establishment politicians
using government power to cr to file
criminal charges against members of the
previous administration for the love of
god
this country is being ripped apart and
it's at the highest possible levels you
you throw away everything else you throw
away the january 6 you show it you throw
away the riots you throw in you pretend
like none of that ever happened and you
come out and you say that there is a
panel members of congress
who are issuing subpoenas against the
previous executive branch's
administration and trying to put them in
prison like steve bannon now they're
saying they want criminal charges
against mark meadows they are literally
trying to imprison the previous
administration and it was these same
people who claimed trump was the bad guy
for saying lock her up in 2016. and it
was funny and he didn't do anything the
dude didn't even fire fauci but i will
absolutely state trump was definitely a
part of this this sundering in the
united states but you but i'm going to
say one more time we don't need to talk
about antifa we don't need to be talking
about proud boys we can just talk about
members of congress who are who are
filing subpoenas against members of the
administration and members of the media
you don't have to like alex jones he is
a media personality and as much as
people don't wanna don't wanna hear me
say it i'm gonna say it alex jones runs
a news organization
now you can hate him which is protected
on the first amendment that's right and
now they're coming after him they're
filing expenses and and this is what
alex is arguing that he's got a first
amendment right here to do what he does
he does but look at what is happening
man they have lost the plot i mean you
look at the stuff they're talking about
with joe manchin they're like one man
who's the real president is it joe
manchin or is it joe biden mentions a
senator from west virginia when was he
going to be on your side no they demand
fealty just because joe manchin is a
democrat they demanded that he do
whatever they want him to do and when he
doesn't
man they're going absolutely insane
against him claiming that he that body
needs to slam the boot down i'll tell
you this man every step of the way we
have seen dramatic escalations and what
is leading to this country being ripped
apart and we are watching it right now
and then when a cia advisor professor
lady comes out and she's like yeah it's
happening it's trump's fault by the way
but it's happening i'll be like it
doesn't matter if she thinks it's
trump's fault what matters is she thinks
it's happening because you've got a
bunch of people who now think it's
happening here's another crazy thing too
you said earlier you said a grand jury
and was convened simply to indict trump
you know yeah that's right that's crazy
because so here's the thing about grand
juries grand juries typically like they
they've been working together for you
know weeks or months on end and they've
seen and heard a bunch of cases the fact
that they're convening a grand jury
solely
for
donald trump is crazy to me that's
that's wild because that's not normal
that's out of protocol let's let's let's
let's call let's call that political and
um a bit hyperbolic in a sense i i i'm
sure they'll tell you well the scope of
our investigation is fraud into the
trump administration or something like
that but we got the story man yeah this
is this is this has been news for the
past couple months that high profile or
i should say like that that individuals
working within the trump administration
including journalists have been
subpoenaed to testify on a grand jury to
to indict donald trump
there and now it is being speculated he
will be indicted and if he's indicted he
will not be able to run in 2024. wow the
nation.com which is a leftist
publication said donald trump will not
be running for president 2024 so
something to that effect and the first
paragraph is donald trump will be
indicted for fraud and this will prevent
him from running the witch hunts is real
fraud let me let me ask you you have
experience with grand juries maybe a
little worse yeah how often do they
retire that's why that's why this is
weird to me because here's the thing the
federal court system everyone is in it
so it would happen all the time i'd go
into grand jury i'd present my case
right some drug case whatever it may be
and then there'd be an fbi agent come
after me he'd go and do bank robbery
then there'd be a d agent he'd come in
and do a drug case there'd be an atf
agent come in and do somebody for phone
and possession so we all would use the
same grand jury which is weird to me
because that grand jury will hear
hundreds of cases over the span of a few
months that's how grand jury works at
the federal system and then you come in
you testify you tell the facts of your
case you're in there with your
prosecutor you step out your prosecutor
comes out true bill bang and then you
get your this is state level just to
clarify oh it's state yeah new york
state state yep
so the fed's so i'll tell you this
that's very interesting so that tells me
that the feds probably didn't want it
and it went to the state because any
ausa would love to do to do a case like
this especially where new york exactly
is this is this
southern yeah so so it's probably new
york city so it falls under southern
district new york which is a very
aggressive prosecutorial office it's
actually one of the best in the country
in the southern district of new york
they have said they've done all the big
mafia cases they do the big racketeering
cases etc so they do big sexy cases like
this so i'm surprised that the feds
didn't take it so that tells me they
probably didn't want it and this they
said you know what we'll run with it
with in your experience i know fed's
different from state but how what
percentage
do they were like what percentage of uh
of grand juries of like cases are
returned as indictments almost if you're
going 95 yeah because because by the
time here's how how tight the reason why
the federal system doesn't lose is
because
by the time you take a case to an ausa
and you present it and you guys gather
your evidence and you actually have
enough to indict that prosecutor is
ready for trial guys
at the federal system
they're ready for trial that's why the
feds rarely lose because prosecutors
don't take cases unless they know
they're going to win they don't want to
go to trial they want to win
so and so if they don't take it this
tells me right now it probably tried to
go federal they said hell no we're not
going to win this thing and then they
say you know what we'll take it so
i gotta say i
very interesting grand juries are not
like like full-on trials you know where
it's difficult and there's it's
non-adversarial this means that the
state walks into a bunch of people and
says here's what they're going for
they're claiming that donald trump
inflated the value of his buildings to
secure loans which is fraud something
that affects okay so i just want to
clarify with the state system i don't
know how often the grand jury convenes
but i know at the federal level they
typically go for a few weeks to a few
months my understanding is that grand
juries almost always issue indictments
because they're not looking yeah they
always do almost right because they're
looking for a preponderance of evidence
so that means someone from the state is
going to walk across
probable cause because it's criminal
if it's go if so so if i thought a grand
jury just needs a little bit more than
probable cause no no probable cause so
so to return a criminal indictment yes
wow probable cause so so at the federal
level i mean regardless the united
states is probable cause right you need
probable cause to effect an arrest right
but for an indictment or a criminal
complaint whatever charging document you
want to use in information it's always
probable cause but um
but the fact that the state didn't take
it i mean sorry the feds didn't take it
is alarming to me because normally they
would do something like this so what
probably happened is this this the feds
are rarely going to charge a charge that
the state is also going to charge so for
example if the feds wanted to do a fraud
case they would deconflict with the
state and then one of them would take it
so the fact that the feds don't have it
in the state has it tells me probably
went to the state they did a grand jury
convened and then they uh and then they
presented the case to the grand jury the
state system is a little bit different i
just i just confirmed it you're right
it's probable cause
trump's getting indicted so it's crazy
this is a plan so that he can't run
basically on purpose that's the point
that could be it there's there's there's
there's there's no way i would ever
believe it otherwise and there's so many
people i got i got a i covered this you
know like last week and i get these
emails from salty you know democrats or
whatever anti-trump people and they're
like no his crimes are finally catching
up to him and i'm like oh sh if the
dude's been this active everywhere for
this long you think they wouldn't have
come after him for anything he was doing
they're coming after him because trump
i guess the argument is he was obsessed
with the net worth the value of his
properties and so he inflated their
value okay well are you going to explain
to the grand jury that property values
are nebulous
like if i were to ask you like your
property values how do you determine the
property value
an appraisal but that's always it
changes with all the time and you can
get a different appraiser and give you a
different number for sure exactly so
they're coming after trump basically
because he was like you got a building
worth 500 million and he goes um you
know probably worth 550 you know because
we did improvements on it i'm gonna get
a loan and they're like that's fraud
it's like uh and it's commercial too so
it has even more checks and balances so
i would love you know what i want i
would love if they actually do uh follow
through and he gets charged and
everything else like that i would like
to read either the indictment or the
criminal complaint that was filed in
support well it was more than likely an
indictment because it convened a grand
jury so it's probably going to be an
indictment it's not going to be a
criminal complaint so let me just ask
everybody who
doubting the idea of a civil war do you
think if donald trump is indicted and
can't run that his supporters that
people on the right are going to be like
i'll say this
it's because you mentioned some
fantastic points earlier about all the
things going on let's add to that the
fact that the
uh you know inflation is here you know
what 40 to 50 of the us currency in
circulation right now was printed in the
last 18 months
let's talk about the financial side too
you know fiat currency nowadays is is
literally dwindling hyperinflation is
going to rear its ugly head any time now
bloomberg said spend your paycheck as
soon as you get yeah like it's it's
crazy so so you got the polarization
between the two parties right between
the democrats and the and the
republicans you got this craziness that
went down at capitol hill you got the
fbi over here going after dudes for
misdemeanors you know what i'm saying to
try to send a message you got them
trying to indict trump by the state you
know clearly the feds didn't want to
take it out of the most aggressive
federal prosecutorial office in the
country by the way and
it i mean yeah th this insane i wouldn't
be
she's not crazy is this woman from the
cia is not crazy because there's a lot
of things in play here yeah look in in
2017 i was like man if this kind of
ideological you know conflict escalates
it's going to reach the highest levels
of government and people have repeatedly
said i was crazy i was crazy i was crazy
i was crazy now most people i think who
say that are typically on the left
because they just don't they're like nah
the establishment's the best it'll never
happen the security state now look where
we are
thanks for checking out this segment
from the tim cast irl podcast if you
want to watch live you can check out
this channel monday through friday at 8
00 pm and don't forget to smash that
like button subscribe to this channel
and if you want more unfiltered and
uncensored content with all of these
guests go to timcast.com and become a
member all of these guests you know and
love in exclusive segments on our
website where we are unrestricted in
what we talk about so you'll definitely
not want to miss it thanks for hanging
out we'll see you all next time
you